ça m'est arrivé dans le métro tout à
l'heure en arrivant dans l'émission j'ai
pris un ticket et les contrôleurs sont
rentrés dans dans la RAM et mon mari mon
ticket j'aurais dû le ticket contraire
sur l'adresse à mon voisin et on dit
ticket et lui il a dit et toi tu es qui
[Applaudissements]
tu as vu
il fait une belle entrée c'est une très
belle tu veux en faire une pour lui
écoute c'est un mec toi
c'est un mec il a étudié en France toute
sa vie
et son père lui dit coup de cheveux pas
venir pour les vacances viens au village
s'il te plaît pour les vacances ça me
ferait du bien tu sais que ta mère
depuis qu'elle est morte moi je suis
tout seul et tout viens viens me voir
alors il va y passer ma conseil avec son
père pendant 15 jours il était mon fils
s'il te plaît dans le village tout le
monde me demande qu'est-ce que tu fais
dans la vie et je sais pas écoute papa
moi je suis devenu vétérinaire
mon fils qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
vétérinaire parce que ils vont pas
comprendre déjà moi déjà j'ai pas
compris qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
écoute moi vétérinaire ben je parle aux
animaux et les animaux me parlent il a
dit tiens par exemple tu as vu la petite
chèvre que tu as le dégoûte pas avec
elle depuis que ta mère elle est morte
[Applaudissements]
dans un bar il est déjà bourré et dit
bonjour
[Musique]
whisky et ça y est ça commence
[Applaudissements]
c'est une famille adore leur mamie c'est
leur maminette à eux vraiment c'est leur
grand amour mais la pauvre elle est très
très vieille et peut plus monter les
escaliers c'est tout est un problème
avec elle décide de la mettre dans une
maison attention à la maison la très
très grande classe c'est 6000 euros par
mois pour te dire il se saigne ces gens
d'endroits tu lèves la main tac
quelqu'un qui vient s'occupe de toi à
fond il a mettre devant une banquette
qui est elle-même devant une baie vitrée
avec la forêt de l'autre côté dans le
cadre magnifique dansant un lapin une
biche tu vois qui passe dis bon mamie
voilà on va te laisser là on viendra
demain comment ça se passe tu vois et un
moment la mamie ça manquait
mais penché un peu
dangereusement sur le sur le côté gauche
tac et un jeune homme qui arrive
bien bien droite
20 minutes après ma mamie elle se fait
pencher comme ça dangereusement de
l'autre côté un autre jeune homme qui
arrive hop il remet la mamie droite tu
vois nickel et le lendemain donc la
famille arrive alors mamie dit la
literie mais vous pouvez passer savoir
j'ai jamais dormi comme ça le chef trois
étoiles manger des des trucs à dire
juste un petit truc c'est con parce que
ça ça gâche tout le mec qui dit comme ça
m'a mis ça gâche tout vas-y dis-moi je
vais leur parler au prix que ça coûte et
ben elle dit écoute je sais pas pourquoi
mais il m'empêche de péter
le niveau parce que c'est l'histoire de
l'histoire d'une comment dire ça se
passe dans une au départ dans une boîte
de nuit il y a un garçon un gros
dragueur et il a une croise une fille
très jolie et tout ça et ils partent
ensemble et font l'amour toute la nuit
vers 3h du matin il est épuisé et il
sort de la chambre et la la femme elle
est sur le lieu fait je veux de l'amour
je veux de l'amour je veux de l'amour je
veux de l'amour
il est vexé mais vexé comme les hommes
peuvent être vexé dans ce genre de
situation
et il appelle des copains qui sont des
balaises et ils s'enferme avec la femme
il reste deux jours au bout de deux
jours elle va te plaire aux deux bouts
je les ressorti ils sont comme ça la
femme elle est sur les fiches je veux de
la montre
il appelle les champions du monde
il reste une semaine avec elle il
ressort comme ça elle est sur les fesses
qui va au zoo de tout à l'heure il va
voir le gorille au doigté et il explique
chaque amour il fait un coup de craie
sur le mur
longtemps la jambe une semaine disons 15
jours au bout de 15 jours la femme
ressortait comme ça
je veux de la créer
j'en ai une petite moi c'est un italien
en américain et un Algérien ils sont
dans le désert et dans le désert on leur
a dit vous avez le droit de prendre une
chose avec vous pour vous protéger une
soleil américain il prend un parasol
comme ça dit voilà s'il y a trop de
soleil je prends le parasol et je vais
me faire un petit coin d'ombre l'italien
dis-moi je vais prendre une gourde avec
de l'eau comme ça s'il fait trop chaud
je vais m'hydrater et l'Algérie elle dit
moi je vais prendre une portière comme
ça si il fait trop chaud je vous la
fenêtre
[Applaudissements]